let's go to our next caller from the
five one two area code caller from five
one two please tell us your name and go
right ahead
hi am I on yes you are
who's this oh hi David Omar from Texas
okay go ahead Omar
okay so I asked you questions I seen
your videos about the rise of
anti-semitism in some subsets some
groups on the left right so my question
is how do we combat that man I mean so
let's see there's a couple different
steps one is you're never going to
successfully fight anti-semitism from
the left until the brazen anti-semites
are denounced rather than welcomed and
praised right so I've talked about the
writers of the women's March like Tameka
Mallory and Linda Sarsour and some
others they just think for example Louis
Farrakhan from the Nation of Islam is
just this great guy right so number one
you can't have that until you either
ostracize the anti-semites or ostracize
the lovers of the anti-semites you're
not really going to be able to
successfully push that out and then you
need to just you know start the dialogue
about how whatever your position is on
the status of American Jews in 2018 in
the United States that it's important
not to forget that we're talking about a
group that is tiny right point 19
percent of the world population and
historically one of the most oppressed
groups the fact that American Jews are
doing okay over the last thirty years
shouldn't make us forget the historical
realities if that makes it all mark yeah
she actually blocked me on Instagram in
the source or oh yeah okay well I don't
know anything about that I don't know
what you did do right yeah I kept asking
her if she ever denounced or is planning
to denounce Louis Farrakhan and she just
bought me oh yeah well that's that's a
good question and you know part of the
problem is it's not a question that they
really want to answer and there's two
ways that they approach one is saying
I'm gonna block you and not talk to you
right suppress the conversation
number two is basically saying if you
criticize Louis Farrakhan you are
ignoring all of the great things he's
done for black people and it's like
listen that doesn't
you know Henry Ford did amazing things
for cars but the guy was sympathetic to
Hitler and for that we can criticize him
regardless of what he did with the
assembly line right so it's sort of it's
it's what about ISM right oh and my
second question was what would have to
happen for you to do a Spanish version
of the show or any you know segment in
Spanish uh what would have to happen I
think you know really well with Latinos
yeah that's interesting I mean let the
problem it I would love to do Spanish
content but I can't really do Spanish
content on my english-language platforms
because their English language so I'm
basically starting from scratch if I
want to do spanish-language stuff and I
think I'm too old to rebuild the show
from the ground up at this point you
know yeah yeah well thank you for
answering my questions and I love the
show you guys are great thank you
appreciate it Omar yeah thank you so
much for the call